[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
jon stewart gets on fox news
they finally let him on fox news
so he can tell the truth about
republicans about ted cruz
being super excited for [ __ ] over the
veterans making sure that veterans don't
get health care republicans hate
veterans
republicans hate veterans not only do
they [ __ ] hate veterans they love to
celebrate when they give veterans a
really good [ __ ] when they give them
a really good [ __ ] in congress
when there's a bill there that's going
to help veterans get health care save
their lives
help it help help give them
some sort of actual
life
of that they have left after they've
served their country and breathed in
toxins
and they're dying from those toxins ted
cruz is real excited when he takes money
away from them veterans
he's [ __ ] so excited he's gonna fist
bump we heard about a [ __ ] fist bump
all week last week for the media every
[ __ ] day they were in the goddamn
white house press room asking about the
president united states joe biden fist
bumping with bone saw that was the
[ __ ] number one headline they
couldn't let it the [ __ ] go
as if it mattered
well you know what fist bump matters
when republicans are fist bumping each
other in the senate
after voting after passing the bill
and on a technicality they decide not to
john stewart is pissed i'm pissed
veterans should be pissed
republican voters should be pissed they
claim they love veterans
you see all these signs out there in
these yards support the troops
support them going to war not support
them when they get sick because we sent
them to war
i don't support them then
why would a republican want to support a
soldier
after after we've sent them the war and
they're sick and they can't fight for us
anymore what good are they now
republicans say
[ __ ] them we're just
leave them on the their own
and not only that celebrate on the
senate floor
celebrate they're so excited that they
own the libtards folks
they're so excited
that they got back at joe manchin
for making a deal with schumer oh [ __ ]
joe manchin we did it we [ __ ] him
veterans
this is their cruelty
this is their lack of empathy this is
the [ __ ] show that we are living with in
this country where we're at the
intersection of wrestlemania in real
life because to ted cruz that [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
it's more about the performance than it
is about the actual government and
actual policy
go back to cancun you [ __ ]
why texas gives him
any more than one goddamn second of
their time is beyond me and anyone who
votes for ted cruz in texas you hate
veterans too
i said it you [ __ ] hate veterans
you're unamerican
you pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
stop voting for these [ __ ] vile
[ __ ] as jon stewart said
yesterday
which is which is a huge change in our
political discourse folks it's a huge
change yesterday what jon stewart did
for 10 minutes in front of a microphone
and then he continued he did not stop
john stewart pointed at the capitol and
called republicans those [ __ ]
because let's be clear about what
happened yesterday this oh both parties
are the same it's all the same no matter
who you elect [ __ ] here's another
[ __ ] example that i can give you here
on our show
of how both these both parties are the
same is nonsense and andrew yang needs
to take his new party and shove it up
his [ __ ] ass
because they're not the same that's all
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
and yesterday was a clear example of
that
there wasn't democrats destroying this
bill making sure that veterans didn't
get the health care that they need
to survive and have quality of life as
they're dying
from the toxins that they breathed in
as they protected us overseas during war
it was not democrats that's not who jon
stewart was calling [ __ ]
that's not who he was saying they don't
work for the people and they don't give
a [ __ ] about the veterans
they wouldn't even meet with the
veterans groups just just to act like
they were gonna support him
they couldn't even muster up enough
courage to act like they were gonna
support him
and when they did mitch mcconnell you
piece of [ __ ]
they cowered they cowered
and of course they did because they are
[ __ ] cowards
the tail is wagging the dog
and it's all about owning the libtards
every
last [ __ ] bit of it
every last bit of it and they're excited
about it
i'm gonna show you a clip i mean it
ain't very long it doesn't take very
much
to understand how excited they were
about taking money away from veterans
healthcare
veterans that need it desperately like
they can't wait
they're dying as we speak some of them
have died
trying to fight for this [ __ ] bill
and it already passed
and for them to act like that there's
some kind of [ __ ] thing that changed
in this bill they're full of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
absolutely full of [ __ ] and i think jon
stewart deserves the
congressional medal of honor
for using his platform and his
microphone unselfishly
to make sure these people are [ __ ]
heard
he did it with the first responders at 9
11 and now he's doing it with these
veterans
and it's a great service to our country
it's a great service to our democracy
and he's clearly not doing it in any
selfish fashion
no self-promotion nothing
he's not pimping his show or pimping his
celebrity he's only yelling and
screaming because people will listen
when he does it
and the political discourse of him
standing there in front of cameras and
calling them [ __ ]
that's this that's a sea change folks
when the entire country pays attention
when jon stewart calls republicans
[ __ ] not oh them that the other
side
are some conservatives
there are there are there are
conservatives in the in the republican
senate caucus no he called them
[ __ ]
three four times he called them
[ __ ]
throw in some more expletives that's the
discourse that we need [ __ ] them
go after him
hard it's enough of this
soft gloving these [ __ ] these
fascists
and yesterday their fascism was just
pure cold-blooded cruelty as jon stewart
put it just [ __ ] cruelty
it was to punish those veterans to own
the libs
that's what they did that's what they
said they did but they don't give a [ __ ]
about they don't give a [ __ ] about their
constituents they don't give a [ __ ]
about veterans
they don't give a [ __ ] about anything
but their own little power on social
media and their ability to get on fox
news oan
and newsmax which jon stewart rebutted
yes he finally worked his way on fox
news this morning
which is good
he was on newsmax yesterday
actually feeding a true sandwich to
those people
for the two minutes that he was on there
i mean jesus christ they don't get a a
diet of the truth at all so two minutes
it's like a [ __ ] truth buffet to
these dumb [ __ ]
and it's about goddamn time
maybe just maybe some of these dumb
[ __ ] out there that still don't
see that the republican party are a
bunch of traitorous treasonous bastards
fascists that want to overthrow our
democracy for their own power
maybe people will wake the [ __ ] up and
realize that they're not for you they're
not doing this for you they're not
they're not talking about drag shows and
monkey pox being gay and all this [ __ ]
all this garbage christian nationalism
you [ __ ] name it
children's genitalia they can't let the
crt thing go it's just on and on and on
with this nazi ass [ __ ]
and the only reason why is to distract
you stupid bastards
into believing that they're for you when
they don't give a [ __ ] rat's ass
i mean jesus christ they've been
bitching for months and months and
months about inflation and prices rising
and just a hint just the hint that we're
working our way into a recession
intentionally
by the way intentionally by raising the
price of money
we're doing it intentionally they're
raising the price of money it's going to
cost you more for money which means
you're going to hold on to it that's
their plan
their plan is to raise interest rates so
it costs you more to buy [ __ ] and then
when it costs you more to buy [ __ ]
you'll go nah that's too expensive now
i'll hold my money
but what about inflation isn't that
supposed to be the thing oh my god
inflation inflation
but now they're bitching about recession
they can't make up their [ __ ] minds
that's because it's not about it's not
about democracy it's not about the
country it's not about their
constituents it's not about the people
it's only about their [ __ ]
power that's it that's it
they're [ __ ] fascist
and they'll use any kind of scapegoat
they can to hold on to that power
jesus christ yesterday
donald trump was
sucking off the saudis
and acting like 9 11 he didn't know how
9 11 happened
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
are you [ __ ] kidding me
these same [ __ ] idiots that show up
at his rallies and his hats and cheer
him on and say build a wall
they're the ones who should hate the
saudis for what happened on 9 11
if they had any kind of inclination of
the truth and that's the problem
that's the problem here
there's a small small percentage of
people in this country it's a large
number of people but there's a small
percentage that absolutely will not
listen to the truth no matter what
[ __ ] them
we don't need them we don't need them
only you need to engage in your
democracy [ __ ] [ __ ] the people who don't
want to engage
ignore them
but these fascists inside of our
government and that are trying to take
over our democracy we can't ignore them
we have to stay vigilant there's a lot
of video i want to get to you know it's
friday
it's friday so we got bonehead of the
week
gabe sanchez is going to join us that's
right gabe sanchez is back
i think he's still
um he's still in a bunker
somewhere
but he's back
and he's going to join us for bonehead
of the week
hopefully he'll search search the surf
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
with us too because man i got a lot of
video to get to today
i don't know if you guys noticed but
yesterday alex jones was on trial
he's gonna go [ __ ] bankrupt
i think they're just deciding the actual
amount of money in this trial i think
that's what this is
it's very unclear to me at this point i
need to bring on a legal expert or
something i'm very unclear in this case
maybe leo af um we'll cover it this
weekend tomorrow
uh what this actually is with this alex
jones
because they already won their case but
they i think they just have to decide
the amount of money but
the drama is definitely there i showed
you a video yesterday of alex jones
outside the courthouse when we had
jessica denson on
and alex jones is like oh the media is
on trial here
and the journalist who was recording him
is like no literally
literally you're on trial that's why i'm
here
is to report on you being on trial not
me you
[ __ ]
bonehead well yesterday i i was in and
out um of the stream
for
uh the alex jones infowars trial i i was
in and out i'd go watch it for a little
bit and then and watch something else
and i go back and check in to see how it
was going and it was not going well for
infowars at all i'm going to show you a
few clips of that um
i i would suspect this morning that the
judge is going to hold
them in contempt of court possibly
hopefully they jail those [ __ ]
for the time being for contempt
and just you know bring them out in
[ __ ] handcuffs and set them in the
seat while this trial is ongoing
uh you'll you'll see what i mean when i
show you this clip of his co-host or his
sidekick whatever the [ __ ] this guy's
name is i think his last name is owen or
some [ __ ] this is a guy that
has also i think been charged with the
some stuff for january 6th yeah that's
right he's a seditionist he's an
insurrectionist huh
boy that's that's uh
news
for infowars really they're they're
insurrectionist over there they're
traitors to our democracy surely not yep
but
the judge
specifically asked and i love i love the
attitude
of this [ __ ] idiot from infowars he's
like oh i have no idea where you're
trying i can't recall i can't recall
it's the same marjorie taylor green [ __ ]
that we saw when she was trying to um
trying to keep herself on the ballot i
don't recall i don't recall i don't i
don't recall being a piece of [ __ ] i
don't recall saying that stuff i don't
recall lying he didn't recall anything
but when he needs to recall something
boy he can pick it right out of his
memory just like that
so we're going to watch that video we
also have some video of kevin mccarthy
this morning he's making news this
morning by lying about a phone call from
cassidy hutchinson that's right he's
lying
i'm gonna say it into a microphone kevin
mccarthy you're [ __ ] lying
you're lying you're [ __ ] lying and
i'm i'm
this is more i don't recall i don't
recall i don't recall being treasonous i
don't recall being a traitor i just
don't recall it
the only thing i recall is not liking
democracy i hate democracy i hate
america
but i don't recall being a treasonous
bastard no you don't recall that do you
kevin mccarthy you piece of [ __ ]
so kevin mccarthy's memory is a little a
little uh
on the outs this morning
now let's see what else do we have in in
the in the news
uh the federalist
is absolutely terrified oh they're
terrified
they're terrified of the popular vote of
course they are
of course the federalists are absolutely
terrified of the popular vote they do
not like democracy i've been telling you
this
for months and months and months they
are
terrified terrified of democracy it is
the mortal enemy of fascism that's why i
keep encouraging you to engage
go engage
in your democracy
rather it's
like i do talking into a microphone
coming here and participating in the
chat
finding other people that you can
connect with and network with going
supporting candidates whether it be
making phone calls writing postcards
sending text messages knocking on doors
hell if you got a little extra cash
these people are gonna need money to win
these races
is what they're gonna need speaking of
races the uh the race in wisconsin of
ron senator ron johnson is heating up
uh cerro sarah uh go
gowalski i believe is how you say her
name
nice polish name there she she's
dropping out of the race to make a way
for mandela barnes we watched as um a
very rich man walked out of the race uh
to make way for mandela barnes because
it is
becoming clear that mandela barnes can
beat ron johnson and democrats are
banning together to make sure
that they take that senate seat so it
looks like not only are the seats in
ohio pennsylvania in play but it looks
like the seat that ron johnson that the
treasonous piece of [ __ ] putin's puppet
looks like his seat is now in play and
the only reason why is because ron
johnson decided to rerun you guys
remember several months ago when he
decided to run everyone's like wait a
second didn't you say ron johnson that
you would only serve so many terms and
he's like yeah but putin says i have to
run
my my my bladdy daddy says i must run he
needs someone in the senate
with his with his knee pads on
oh bladdy daddy needs fellatio in the
senate and i'm it baby
so ron johnson decides to run well it
looks like that was a mistake for
republicans
now
as as the democrats move out of the way
for mandela barnes
to take
to take the nomination for the
democratic ticket to beat the [ __ ] at
iran johnson
so folks there's plenty of places to
engage even if you're not in these
states
another state to engage in is texas
better o'rourke raising more money than
greg abbott piling mountains of money on
top of greg abbott
that's right that's what democrats have
to do don't listen to these [ __ ]
dumbasses out there saying not to give
money to democrats because it's all
their fault
well
again another example of yesterday of
how it's not their fault it's [ __ ]
republicans people
there's only one party only one party
interested in democracy only one
that's even interested in it the other
party is not interested they are
treasonous bastards they do not want our
constitution they do not want our former
government they do not like our republic
they are not
patriots
they are unamerican
full stop period and a sentence
so if you're pro-democracy at all at all
just at all
like you're like you know i don't like
what the democrats do i don't like this
i don't like that but i'm for democracy
i want to keep like you know the right
to vote
you know maybe freedom of speech freedom
of religion separation of church and
state those sorts of things you know
fundamentals principles of american
society
our form of government and maybe maybe
just maybe i should vote for someone
who's for democracy well they will not
have republican after their name
if you're voting for someone who's
pro-democracy you definitely are not
voting for a [ __ ] republican
and that is no more clear than yesterday
well i mean it
every day they serve this up of why
why they're fascist and why they're
anti-democracy and why they're not for
the people at all they're only for
themselves they're only for their power
so we can work these races we can work
these states and we can make joe manchin
irrelevant again
there's talk about kirsten cinnamon joe
manchin supporting some bills in the
senate well we if we get out and do the
work and engage in democracy actually do
democracy folks
we don't have to worry about matching
the cinema anymore [ __ ] them he'll let
them go be republicans at the point
where we win those races [ __ ] him [ __ ]
him who gives a [ __ ]
we have 53 52 54 votes
in the senate we're good to go we don't
even need a tie breaker at that point
then we just have to worry about maybe
doing something about the old guard but
first first we have to do the politics
before we ever decide on policy
because right now
because of republicans we cannot do
policy
in the senate it's the problem that is
the problem the republicans in the
senate are the problem so let's fix it i
say let's fix it
uh some more
news um is
it looks like exxon has
record profits again
more with the inflation recession
[ __ ] talk uh rather it's the media
the right wing or anyone who really just
doesn't know the fundamentals of our
economy uh understands that exxon and
the in the oil companies are the ones
gouging your gas prices that's the
reason why you're paying so much money
at the [ __ ] pump and until you start
blaming the actual [ __ ] cause of the
problem and band together
and turn the tide they'll they'll keep
gouging you
as long as you're blaming someone other
than them well [ __ ] they're just gonna
keep gouging you
now we also have news out of spain
shakira this is this is a this is a
crazy story uh she owes 23 and a half
million dollars in a tax fraud case
and apparently they're asking for eight
years
in spain
uh to put her in prison i i didn't know
this was going on
that's that that's that's crazy that's
crazy now also in kentucky there's big
floods uh president biden is making way
for fema funds and emergency relief
funds to go to kentucky
uh to help those in need of the flood
which we should do uh they're americans
in this country now we should not do
what fascists do and decide that we're
gonna pick out which citizens are more
are better than others and which ones
deserve
uh
the money and you know we don't
we definitely do not want to do that we
want to make sure
that all americans are safe and in
kentucky there's a lot of floods right
now there's a few deaths so the
president united states is making way
for those funds not to go to kentucky
which
i like to see a statement from the
senators from kentucky like rand paul
and mitch mcconnell who have worked hard
to make sure that emergency funds don't
go to certain states because they see
them as liberal
you [ __ ] idiots
you [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
i bet we won't hear a goddamn word from
rand paul and we probably we will
it's probably bile disgusting words is
what he'll say
so we're gonna have bone end of the week
at the top of the second hour it's
friday bone end of the week you know we
do a poll every single week
on our twitter account at
tonymichaelspot go follow us there you
can vote for bonehead of the week every
single week and you vote you decide we
break it down in the second hour every
single friday because we broadcast two
hours two hours every single day here on
youtube twitter and twitch noon eastern
11 central nine pacific and we simulcast
from the midas touch facebook page don't
forget to download the episode as well
google spotify apple wherever you
download
your podcast your favorite directory
you can download it there seven days a
week we do a best of on saturday and
then we actually cut out bonehead of the
week we cut it out and we post it on
sunday on those directories so if you
love bonanza leak which i do i'm very
fond of bonehead of the week you can go
just listen to bonehead of the week on
sundays but don't forget also to
subscribe to the youtube channel because
we post bonehead of the week and the
best of the week here on the tony
michaels podcast on youtube so don't
forget to subscribe here on
youtube
i'm glad to have gabe sanchez back i
don't know if he's ready yet um to do to
surf the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends i don't know if he's gonna i
don't know if he's gonna surf with us
arby's just gonna do bonehead
i'm not really sure yet but he is back
he is back in action he's i think he's
still in his underground bunker
somewhere but he actually has internet
service that will allow him to stream
this morning
so
let's go to the break when we come back
we will surf the tweety tweets and
trendy trends don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day i'm
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
i think we're sticking to the break
we're gonna surf the tweety tweets and
trendy trends as gabe sanchez prepares
to join us soon
soon he will join us gabe is back
gabe is back today
again he's getting set up
um he made it back to his bunker luckily
uh so he'll get set up here soon so
he'll join us and to surf the tweety
tweets and trendy trends like i said we
got a lot of news uh to get to today
um before we get to bonehead of the week
but let's uh
let's see
um
let's see what else did we have is there
anything new trending
um
because i know i know
things are fast moving oh will smith is
now
is now trending but jon stewart has a
new um
clip today from the fox news network
news quote unquote
[ __ ] um he actually made it on there
to talk about this veterans issue so
let's do this let's start the countdown
let's surf the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends with the [ __ ] list roundup
start the countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list welcome welcome welcome
back to the journey michael's podcast
we've reached the part of the show where
we round up all the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends
with the [ __ ] lister roundup
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends
so let's get to it let's not waste a lot
of time we got a lot of video i want to
show you today
uh there's a lot of things to look at
and to know um some of the news we have
again is leader mccarthy i want to go to
that first here is a clip of him in his
press conference uh lying about his
phone call to cassidy hutchinson let's
listen in cassidy hutchinson testified
so we're going to january's thing yeah
she testified under ode you know what
recession too right well um she
testified under oath saying that you
called her after donald trump said that
what a stupid [ __ ]
what a stupid [ __ ] you know
we're in a recession right
yesterday you were bitching about
inflation
again i i i don't know how to say this
it's not actually a recession yet
it it's getting there though folks and
some people tell me yesterday that this
isn't a recession but they're they're
working hard
to draw us into recession by making your
money more expensive that's what they're
doing
the raising interest rates to try to
draw us into recession to stop inflation
because the opposite of inflation is
recession now it's a very different time
that we have because demand is very high
supply is low for a lot of different
reasons now we're starting to see
headway when we're talking about oil
supply increased supply from the from
the absolute war crimes that vladimir
putin and russia are committing in in
the sovereign nation of ukraine which
there is some news out of ukraine i
believe
but
there's also we're we're we're making
headway from the pandemic getting the
economy back on track and normalizing
the actual economy here for working
class people but it's working class
people that always feel the and lower
class people who always feel the brunt
of a changing economy it doesn't matter
what economy it is
what economy changes we have when the
economy is in a changing phase it is
always the working class that feels the
brunt of that change the most
and the reason why is because the thing
that they have to trade their their
capital that they have to trade in the
economy is their labor so their only
their only token
to the economy is what labor they have
to trade that's it and in a changing
economy
when you're in the changing phases which
we have been in a changing phase a
constant changing phase since 2020.
this is why donald trump failed us not
just because he killed 11 or excuse me a
million people in this country by not
responding to covid
appropriately but he also failed on the
economic points to respond appropriately
the republicans also failed on this
measure
the inflation protection that was going
to happen in the billback better bill or
the big bird bill as i call it
the actual inflation protection that was
going to happen in that bill the
republicans didn't want that and the
reason why they didn't want that is
because they wanted inflation to draw
out of control
and now that the fed is raising interest
rates to cost you the working class
people more money
demand is going to drop because it cost
more so you're gonna hang on to more of
your money
which is only gonna cause the economy to
recess now it is not exactly a recession
yet and the reason why is because
unemployment is still very low
and the reason why that is is because
demand is still at a higher level
than what can be constituted as a
recession
but money is getting more expensive not
just listen goods are expensive your
bread your milk your gasoline that stuff
is more expensive but when money gets
more expensive you're really [ __ ]
you're really [ __ ]
and that's what they want so kevin
mccarthy standing here
trying to avoid a question about his
treasonous his
his treasonous ways and his party's
treasonous ways of how they tried to
overturn the government of the united
states and tear down our constitution
and turn this into a fascist state by
complaining about what he wanted
he wanted a recession he's been com
complaining about inflation
they need to do something about
inflation the economy needs to change
well that's called recession if you're
not inflating you're recessing
get it through your thick [ __ ] skulls
and yeah it's really complicated i
understand that i've got that [ __ ]
[ __ ] already oh it's more complicated
than that yes i get it i understand that
the economy is very complicated
but it's not complicated to understand
what the opposite of inflation is it's
not complicated
and it's not complicated to understand
that the same [ __ ] complaining
month after month day after day every
single hour about inflation are now
getting what they want which is us
dragging us intentionally dragging us
the economy is not reacting in a natural
way here
they're dragging us into a recession and
costing you more money
and now they're going to complain about
what they've been cheering for
[ __ ] [ __ ] you kevin mccarthy you piece
of [ __ ] this is republicans as john
stewart calls them those [ __ ]
that urges told her supporters that they
were going to go to the capitol and you
were concerned about those remarks and
said don't come up here figure it out
don't come up here she said that under
oath now this is he's talking about
cassidy hutchinson testifying under oath
that she talked to kevin mccarthy and
kevin mccarthy told her who she is the
chief of she is the assistant to the
chief of staff
mark meadows who's standing next to
donald trump
tell kevin mccarthy telling her do not
get to not come up here
do not come up here listen to his lies
did you tell her that and why were you
concerned about the prospect of donald
trump coming to the capitol on january
beyonce i i don't even call talking here
that day i recall talking to dan scavino
every talk talking to
jared i read call talking to trump
that's what of course of course he
recalls talking to the men
of course he recalls talking to the men
of course he does
course kevin mccarthy recalls that this
is all a bunch of [ __ ] i don't
recall
they're [ __ ] the
the thoughts just leave their mind as
soon as the the
the possibility that they're committing
trees treason works its way into the
narrative
a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
grow some goddamn balls kevin mccarthy
grow some [ __ ] balls and tell the
truth
we all know what happened that day we're
it's becoming more and more clear
americans getting more wise to this and
what i mean by that is not you
pro-democracy people out there that
smoked this out on that day knew that
these republicans are trying to
overthrow our government and they're a
bunch of treasonous traders
there are a bunch of [ __ ] nazis
trying to overthrow our government and
our democracy
but some americans are blind to this
they don't pay attention this stuff but
it's becoming more clear
and let me tell you something i think
it's i think it's very appropriate that
a young woman
recalls exactly what happened but here a
lot like liz cheney said weak feeble old
white men just can't muster up enough
[ __ ] courage to tell the truth you
coward but i talked to on television
like that too
if i talk to her i don't remember it if
it was coming up here i don't think i
wanted a lot of people coming up to the
capitol um but i don't remember the
conversation i i just i just don't
remember i just don't remember i just
don't remember well listen to what he
says about remembering
if he wanted trump to come up or not
listen to this i'm coming to the capitol
i don't remember that do you remember
being concerned about his comments
no but because i didn't watch it
this is what is so confusing
i didn't watch the speech i was working
so i didn't see what was said i didn't
see what went on
uh until after the fact
here it is did you want him to come to
the capitol let's listen to what this
lying piece of [ __ ] has to say no i've
never i've never communicated with about
coming to capital i had no idea he would
come to the capitol i had no idea that
he was even going to come to the capitol
there it is
there it is kevin mccarthy admitting
that cassie hutchinson is telling the
[ __ ] truth right there
i had no idea he planned on coming to
the capitol
he's admitting it right there you know
he's [ __ ] lying
of course of course donald trump wanted
to go to the capitol
to prom to probably help them put the
noose around mike pence's neck on the
gallows they erected
give me a [ __ ] break kevin mccarthy
that's news
that you told her throughout the course
of the week
or she told reassured you through the
course of the week that he was not going
to come to the capitol so apparently
i don't remember having any
conversations with her about coming to
the camp the president coming to the
capitol
you mean that day oh you mean several
days oh we had several conversations i
just don't recall i just don't recall
talking to a young woman about the
president united states coming to the
capitol and overthrowing our government
i just don't recall those conversations
give me a [ __ ] break get the [ __ ] out
of here with this [ __ ]
i just i don't recall any of that i
recall my conversation with dan scavino
i recall yep he remembers talking to the
men that was in the midst of
of the capital people breaking into the
capital me being removed from the office
that's what i call people and the reason
why is because dan scavino and jared
kushner didn't have the guts
didn't have the [ __ ] guts to
sound the alarm
about the president coming to the
capitol that day but cassidy hutchinson
did several days before but he just
can't recall he can't recall that piece
of [ __ ] um this morning the federalist
uh tweets out here
democrats are dangerously close to
changing laws so our president is
elected by popular vote yeah yeah so
what are you scared of [ __ ]
democracy will end the surge of fascism
that's what'll happen that's that's what
will do it
listen listen to the federalists when
they say what the difference is between
republicans and democrats folks
even the federalists knows
even they know
that there's a difference between
democrats and republicans and the
difference is that democrats want
democracy
they're saying it out loud they're
terrified of it i've been telling
gabe how long have i been telling the
folks this
how long have i been telling them that
they're terrified of democracy
forever forever like since i was two
yeah no but here this this morning this
is this is very telling and and this
should knock this
again it's not gonna knock it off but it
should knock this bolt parties are the
same [ __ ] i'm gonna show you a video i
don't know if you watched it i know
you've been kind of out of pocket here i
don't know if you've watched uh ted cruz
fist bumping and cheering that he took
away health care from veterans oh man
he's excited he's [ __ ] yeah excited
yeah he's great hates vets he does he
and he's happy about it like he like not
only not only do they hate veterans they
they they enjoy hating them so much that
they love celebrating on the senate
floor when they give the veterans a good
[ __ ] man right when they give them a
good [ __ ] and take away benefits that
they really should have to save their
lives or have quality of life ah ted
cruz really enjoys that this is the same
party that you know lauren bobert when
they had the state of the union was was
saying how she goes you know she had her
you lie moment right she goes out and
she she starts you know trying to
trying to rally the troops marger taylor
green they both look like they're like
you know
i've seen some comparison photos of them
looking like chimpanzees in a tree like
howling you know over at the president
but in that very same week that she
complained about president biden not
caring for the vets that were overseas
or that had come back
she voted no for this very bill
right so like the hypocrisy within this
party is just dumbfound and especially
when their platform is all about hey we
want 1a 2a and vets we want to care for
you but as soon as you come back you can
go [ __ ] yourselves well here's another
what he wants here's another example of
how they're not the same
here's here's a 187 187
republicans voting against the chip
industry grants
which allows us to make computer chips
here in this country and to make sure
that we can manufacture goods and
services just help the supply chain and
not only that provide americans with
good paying jobs right and they're
voting against it they [ __ ] hate
america they [ __ ] hate it they don't
just take veterans they [ __ ] hate
america so like for me personally like
i'm you know my my background is in the
tech industry right and so you know
previous companies that i've worked at
specifically those who have dealt with
using electronic components right we
have to source those things from
overseas because nobody makes it if you
do make it you can go to like a local
shop or something like that we'll
fabricate those but they're at a higher
cost because the cost of going to
somewhere like uh you know china or
or different areas of that region
is because they have built their whole
industry around that they have literal
uh like uh thank you for welcoming back
it's good to be back within oh yeah oh
yeah by the way
welcome back right right well the
problem was that i was you know not to
go too far but i was a little bit
further down than the seven floors that
i was originally around so that's what
the wi-fi yeah so once i got down eight
nine ten down to some secret floors the
secret 13th floor that soros sent me
down to
let me just say uh no signal no no wi-fi
no cell service it's dead zone down
there oh my god what i want to say is on
the chip industry like manufacturing
these chips
is something that has become
an industry for china it is very
inexpensive at a large scale so if
you're doing that you would go to that
region it's very costly to do that in
america because one we do not have a
whole factory industry based where it's
like to just
if anyone knows anything about this but
to imagine like a literal factory
industry that says hey
our our machines are going to specialize
only
in manufacturing these chips you want to
fabricate these chips on a pcb board
great boom done we can ship these out
thousands within a short amount of time
but if you want to do that within the
u.s we don't have that infrastructure we
didn't invest in that so because of that
and because china is decades ahead of us
in manufacturing and they are looked at
as the specifically this industry right
specifically decades ahead of us in this
industry so we have a shortage and we
say okay fine let's you know and you
will hear this all the time from
republicans i've had co-workers who have
republican families and they've always
brought this up why not just make it in
america okay fine let's make it in
america however when we want to fund and
resource these types of things to build
the infrastructure say hey america is
now going to be the number two science
uh manufacturing uh electronic
technology type of industry
republicans don't wanna back it they
don't wanna put their money where their
mouth is so when you say okay fine what
would you write what would you have them
do they go well i i don't know just like
make it here well it costs a lot it's
fine if you want to prototype something
and make it locally to actually test and
validate an idea
but if you want to use it at a scale
that's like hey i want to send out a
fleet of electronics or devices like
uh those those electro those electric
scooters that are around the cities
those have
ships inside that connect to a cell
tower
that connect to the cloud that go back
and through and cycle through to say oh
yeah you can reserve this uh this elect
this uh
this scooter right now
but the problem is that that republicans
don't want to do that so when it comes
to doing that in the us it is very
costly so trying to trying to do the
same thing that trying to do the exact
same thing that they want to say we do
which is built in america made in the
usa the first america they won't do it
right america first agenda except when
it comes to providing actually doing it
actually doing it right any anything
that actually is for right for america
that is actually good for our country
that is patriotic you would be good for
the people they don't give a [ __ ] and
here's this is tim ryan he's he's a
representative of ohio's 13th district
but he's also the senate candidate in
ohio and he's kicking jd vance's ass and
here is why listen to what he says this
is the first step towards an industrial
policy in the united states of america
and it is time for us to quit the
politics
stop trying to score political points
stop putting party over country
lay down our arms my god if we can't
agree on this what in the hell are we
going to agree on
rebuilding the manufacturing base good
paying jobs union construction out
competing china
national security come on let's do this
let's do it together
but we have
a small group of people
who have hijacked the republican party
in the leadership in this house on the
republican side is more concerned with
defeating democrats than doing something
that's best for the united states of
america we just saw it in the senate
with the burn pits legislation and there
he brings up the burn pits because
that's exactly what it was ted cruz is
fist bumping because he [ __ ] the
veterans to own the libs and he thinks
that's cool he's like this is awesome we
we really own the libs today by making
sure that veterans don't get health care
that they need this is great
like and they were fist bumping right
and here tim ryan's saying exactly like
what the [ __ ] is going on here what are
you people doing you are not american
you are not american you are not
patriotic you are the exact opposite of
that you [ __ ]
we're seeing it here
with the chips legislation party over
country so july 28
2022 is going to be black thursday the
day the republican party gentlemen have
been hijacked and aligned themselves
with communist gentlemen
i love i love when tim ryan i love when
he yeah when he because
tim ryan is no fan of of china and the
reason why is in ohio there's a lot of
union jobs and a lot of those union jobs
count on those chips because there's a
lot of automotive um industry in ohio
and they rely on those chips coming from
china to manufacture other parts here
to or to put to assemble parts here to
get to the auto manufacturers like a lot
of those jobs rely on it yeah and that
supply of parts and and that's why we're
seeing uh now a shortage of brand new
cars right because of that which is only
drawing up the cost of used cars which
now they're going to raise the interest
rates on the working class because
republicans have been bitching about
inflation where and they're drawing us
into a draw intentionally drawing us
into a recession well even that like
even you know bringing up the topic of
cars right you you know we had a
shortage of used cars that were
available because you know uh or at
least uh there there is a high demand
for used cars right now where the price
is like i went in to go renew my or like
you know like kind of like deal with my
lease that i had on my car and they were
like yeah your car right now your used
car for the last three years is now
valued more
than when you got it brand new right
which is insane to think about because
normally it's like oh well you just not
10 to 15k off the lot once you drove it
right nope not like not now not anymore
right and then used cars you know i was
i was discussing like what are my
options like what if i want to you know
lease a new car he's like if you're
going to do it you want to do it right
now because next month which was at the
time
december or january it was like before
or like beginning of 2022.
they were marking up everything 3 to 4k
on the msrp right so these things like
the iot industry which is a huge
industry that relies on anything that
connects to the internet
needs these chips right cars these
devices any you know manufacturing
phones or computers or whatever it might
be like there are chips that need to be
manufactured at a large scale for big
companies and when you have a shortage
then the company says well we wanted to
make this thing but we now only have a
limited supply
right or or one company kind of
monopolizes the market to take say and
say we are now sourcing all the chips
from everywhere because we're willing to
pay top dollar for those things surely
that doesn't affect cost either surely
they didn't exactly know and and and
be it as it may
regardless of that the republicans
definitely would want to lower costs for
it now they wouldn't they would vote for
this [ __ ] bill but a hundred listen
to me
180
of these [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] voted
against american jobs
this is supposed and this is what jon
stewart said yesterday and i think this
is a great phrase this is a great
message if this is america's first then
america's [ __ ] if
this is your idea that what what you
what the image you have then america's
[ __ ] so are you going to sit back as
americans get [ __ ] are you going to do
something about it right because here's
here's the son of a [ __ ] on the floor
of the senate and you can see ted cruz
standing here you also have that [ __ ]
that piece of [ __ ] mushmouth john
kennedy that son of a [ __ ] watch them
watch them get so excited so excited
that they took vital health care cancer
treatments away from people who served
our country
watch
oh yeah fist bump boom got him got him
[ __ ] him got him oh we gave him a good
[ __ ] today
that one dude that was not even like oh
boom that was like a
josh holly standing there behind ted
cruz
is that who that is that might be is
that tom cotton over there no of course
yeah that's tom cotton here and he's oh
he's whis i don't know i it looks like
it he looks like he looks like the crypt
keeper standing over there
in a [ __ ] suit it could be josh
hawley the left i don't know but that's
definitely that's definitely no
mistaking oh that is cancun cruz that is
the uh wish.com version of wolverine
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
everyone in texas who's voted for this
[ __ ] should be ashamed of
themselves and if you're not if you're
not today calling ted cruz's office and
telling him that you once voted and
you'll never vote for his ass again
you're derelict in your duty as an
american that piece of [ __ ]
pulling up his fist and fist bumping to
take away health care from veterans who
were dying after they voted for it they
[ __ ] voted for it it was passed and
on attack
like this is the same thing when mitch
mcconnell says uh oh i'm gonna vote no
on impeaching president trump and then
within the next 15 minutes gives a
speech that says yes trump is in fact at
the uh responsible for inciting this
like they will do whatever they will say
one thing and act another way they will
[ __ ] over americans and not even blink a
[ __ ] eye he will [ __ ] over
constituents and fly to cancun
he will [ __ ] over vets by voting against
the just just
it is insane to think that oh wow i was
overseas and i was i was close these
burn pits and now i'm experiencing
cancer or going through this and i have
health problems
you would think
that someone who they say thank you so
much for serving our country thank you
so much for the service that you did for
however long you served right a few
years many years whatever it might be
thank you so much for laying down your
life
for our safety and freedom freedom right
well then once they come back what does
a veteran have to rely on they go around
they're like okay well i got the vet
services they don't have the proper
funding what about this program well
actually we didn't get it because the
government wouldn't give it to us
because these senators voted against it
then you have this problem where it's
like hey look
i have
i have health issues because i was close
to these burn pits or i was you know
whatever it might be
and they go
look see here's the thing we didn't
really
value your life that much right we
weren't like that grateful for the
service that you did
so you can go [ __ ] yourself and find
your own health care right well and then
why do you and it's like why do you why
why do you think that these veterans
can't find a job they can't pay for
health care they can't get a home they
live on the street they become they
being houseless like
why it's like
health you're
having having good health
is is the first [ __ ] domino in a long
line of things that can go wrong and
then end up with an even worse situation
and these these senators these
republicans representatives anyone in
that party
unless you're speaking up these people
in the republican party do not care
about american lives at all it is not
america first it is me first me first
republican my power first you
you maybe i think about i can go [ __ ]
yourself yeah right yeah go go [ __ ] off
and really um i
here's here's the feeling of the entire
country uh democratic representative
linda sanchez of california i don't know
if this is any relation or not but linda
sanchez of
california
she's a representative she was playing
in the congressional baseball game game
and watch what she does here as she runs
past the dugout of the republicans
[ __ ] you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just straight flips them off
i mean i don't even think i don't even
think it had to be recent events it's
just like look there's a big [ __ ] you
for all this stuff right well i mean
they lost 10 to nothing the democrats
did
but this this moment here is the
is the icing on the cake for me yeah
[ __ ] you guys [ __ ] you right just
doesn't give two [ __ ] it's enough of
this [ __ ] and and like i said in the
beginning in the first 30 minutes the
discourse is changing when jon stewart
when jon stewart can stand in front of a
microphone
and say
those called republicans not democrats
not all senators republicans those
[ __ ] when he says that three or
four times those [ __ ] the
discourse is changing and it's headed in
the right [ __ ] direction here's the
other thing too it is insane that we
have to rely
on a on a comedian right a political uh
satirist comedian
who has
who has dedicated his time because this
is not the first time that he's come
forward to speak on behalf of someone
getting just basic health care
right he did it for the first responders
and it took years
it took [ __ ] years tony for them to
get any sort of acknowledgement and then
to get any sort of funding
like
it's insane that it wasn't the
representatives it wasn't the senators
it wasn't any of them who could get it
done
it was it was a comedian
who was able to to broadcast his message
to get this out and actually defend them
to get these people to [ __ ] move
for just a basic human
care that's all just like hey these
people are now experiencing health
problems because they pulled people out
of the [ __ ] rubble
at 9 11.
and then say you guys won't do [ __ ] and
it's taking years of advocacy and years
of protesting and years of trying to
fight for them to get this basic thing
and it's the same thing here
they just they don't care they give no
[ __ ] about these people it is insane
and again like we have to rely on
someone who is not a representative and
i know people talk about hey john
stewart's remember president or senator
or whatever
but honestly
he's able to get more done with his
platform that's right than any of these
sitting republicans his brilliance his
brilliance and his unselfishness and
using his microphone because jon stewart
actually uh he hasn't he hasn't been on
twitter that long um active yeah but
he's been acting last couple years right
but he actually became active here
recently and he's using and he's you
he's trying to use that microphone for
good as well um there's some news uh
that's broken the last few hours that i
want to give everyone here a sense of
what the difference between the party is
the parties are uh nbc news confirms
that the january 6 committee has
formally formalized a path to share
witness transcripts and evidence with
the department of justice as we uh
watched last month this the select
hearings
uh and this month the select hearings
ongoing there was talk about the
department of justice getting the full
transcripts of all the depositions uh of
some of the clips that we've seen in
those public hearings it looks like
there's an official pathway now for
those scripts to be provided in a legal
form so that they can be used in
criminal trials for the department of
justice to use as discovery and evidence
which is fantastic um that that that is
a big move i figured we wouldn't get
this news until the end of the summer
that there would actually be a path
cleared because i think the department
of justice timetable was to have those
by the end of the year sometime in
december they wanted those transcripts
another piece of news from kyle here is
that the new from speaker speaker pelosi
democrats will vote today uh on an
assault weapons ban legislation so we're
going to get the republicans on record
who want little school children people
in grocery stores people at fourth of
july parades they want them to die [ __ ]
them people they don't care it's more
important it's more important that the
non-militia have weapons of war to to
stoke fear and terrorism in this country
so we're gonna get a vote on that we
know we know there'll be a huge gap in
the two parties there are these parties
are not
the same yeah they're not the same you
would never ever ever see a republican
party
chairing a
commission
where their own party
tried to overthrow the government
cooperating with the department of
justice and criminal probes would not
happen it just wouldn't now
speaking of those two pieces of news the
uh
the guns and the um
the lawsuits i gave yesterday i know you
were kind of out of pocket but i sent
you
a link on youtube yeah hilarious for
alex jones is that that's yeah
and
holy cause i was kind of in and out of
that that trial right yeah yeah and
there's one point in the trial where
alex jones actually gets up these storms
out and i guess he goes on tv and um i
don't have that clip but i do have
another clip of his host owen
owen shrouder schroeder schroeder i
don't know what the [ __ ] his name is
it's [ __ ] guy
you don't need a name you just call him
[ __ ] yeah dumb [ __ ]
captain [ __ ] here our our lieutenant
[ __ ] right now this is uh
this is a different angle than i was
watching yesterday
but watch the judge question this this
[ __ ] idiot
lieutenant [ __ ] here
about what he says on his show watch how
he doesn't recall this is really
this is beginning to seem to be a
pattern with these [ __ ] fascists but
let's listen you testified
let me give context here again this is
the trial of alex jones and this is his
co-host or sidekick or whatever he's
called here yeah
um and he's gonna talk about um the
shows that he was on this week this
judge is questioning about shows that he
had done on infowars this week watching
i think i think sorry you know go ahead
go ahead i think we should uh at some
point i don't know when is their show
live their show is live 11am weekdays
11am 3pm
central yeah i think some point in the
near future we should call in while he
still has a show oh yeah we can
livestream it too yeah yeah yeah live
streaming here and call in
and see if we get through and if we get
through then we should you know just cut
over and just
do that but anyway side note
let's let's listen to the judge here um
and it looks like contempt of of court
is gonna happen with these idiots um and
i hope they i hope they jail them while
this trial is ongoing because it can't
contempt a court but watch
just today
that you
um or a guest or a co-host with mr jones
on tuesday is that right
yes
and
you testified that you did a show and
then a
second show is that right yes
and what were the topics
i mean
were any of the topics of those two
shows this
this uh trial yes
did you and mr jones talk about anything
that happened at the trial
i don't recall exactly what was
discussed
i don't recall exactly what was
disgusting come on give me a [ __ ]
break
yeah we do we do two hours every single
day here and i don't remember exactly
everything i say in every single word
but you would remember something kind of
that big well i mean jesus christ i
would remember if i'm on trial to lose
my entire company
right the company that i work for it was
disclosed um in this trial at one point
i was watching gabe alex jones between i
think it was the years 2018 and 2020 i
believe um they sold 160 million dollars
worth of garbage off their website like
these like these uh snake oil pills and
shitty cells
they sold 100 and
160
million dollars worth of garbage off his
[ __ ] website and this guy here this
owen whoever the [ __ ] this this
character is here who's about to lie to
the judge which is not a good idea by
the way um
he disclosed that he makes i believe his
salary was 125 120 125 something like
that somewhere in that range was how
much money he makes
uh actually doing this so if you are on
the line of losing a salary like that
which is a pretty significant salary in
most parts of the country um especially
in austin texas probably um if you're if
your um
company that you work for that you make
that salary for is at risk of going away
like just poof it's gone um because of
the financial trouble that this trial is
gonna cause for you i think you would
recall if you talked about the [ __ ]
trial yeah
what in the hell come on man
these pieces of [ __ ] this do not recall
this is the same nonsense of oh that's
green that call was perfect down in
georgia it was a perfect call everything
was great everything well i don't recall
if i committed crimes i don't recall
yeah well also what's funny about that
message that he sent i think on true
social was he admitted to more than one
call which is like whoa whoa whoa hold
on how many times did you call oh yeah
yeah exactly which is like that wasn't
that wasn't revealed everyone knows
about the one call that he made but he's
like look it was perfect like it was it
was perfectly fine
and it's all the times that i called to
pressure them to
illegally you're using like calls for
plural what do you mean calls uh right
what else did you say can you imagine
can you imagine um
anyone getting on the phone even like if
he was gonna order
like doordash i would imagine the person
on the other end of the doordash is
recording that phone call there's no way
i would get on a phone conversation with
donald trump without recording that
[ __ ] yeah yeah if i knew it was
like oh hi this is donald trump even if
it was a prank i'd be like look uh
there's nothing to lose here i'm just
gonna write i just gotta record this
somebody said that they were donald
trump we're like oh this is for you know
on behalf of donald trump you're gonna
be on the line i'd be like yeah someone
get another phone let's record this
right now
you know
well let's listen let's listen to the
judge pressure in here as as he doesn't
recall this is hilarious are they still
available for viewing i believe
think you talked about the trial without
talking about what happened at the trial
i'm not sure well you just told me that
the topic
and i'm asking you did you talk about
what happened in this book and you said
i don't remember
well i just don't recall the exact
details i'm not asking you for any
details
did you talk about
things that happened in this program
her line of questioning reminds me
of like when a parent
catches a kid like oh did you
right did you it was the dog maybe it
was the dog you take a couple extra
cookies out of the jar or whatever and
like you know they've got like chocolate
chips or whatever like no i didn't do it
you know it's like are you sure because
look look i we could start over and you
could tell me straight up that you took
him and i won't be mad but i need you to
tell me the truth
and that this kid this guy
is very much a kid right now where he's
like um
i don't i don't i don't know um no uh
well and she's like okay look i'm gonna
ask you one more time
were you on the show and did you talk
about this and he's like uh uh maybe i
don't know i love i love how she's like
okay so if i go back and look at the
tapes yeah
like if i go back and who knows the
answer she knows the answer she's like
i'm leading you to tell me yes you did
talk about it so you might as well just
say it yeah well
it gets worse here it gets worse um for
him his lawyer and alex jones
just in a matter of 30 more seconds here
it gets way worse for them but here's
the thing
is that this is this white male
privilege [ __ ]
where he thinks he has the right to try
to gaslight this judge who is a woman
that's exactly what's happening here he
acts if this was if this was a male
judge this conversation would have went
way differently right way different
situation right right
but here but here he thinks he has this
white privilege he has this power over
this woman who is presiding over this
courtroom and he can just gaslight her
and there's no way she'll find out even
though the tapes she's not smart enough
to figure that out but i'll just say i
don't recall but watch how it gets worse
because it draws in the legal he
[ __ ] draws in the legal team here
gabe watch this
didn't mr renault inform you that you
were under the rule
so
so renault is the lawyer for their team
for alex jones
and
and what rule he says what rule like you
know that as if there's no rules for him
again this is that mentality right of
this white male prim what rules i don't
have any rules yeah what are you guys
talking about why dude what are you
talking about i get to do whatever i
have never had an issue before i can i
could say and do whatever i want with
zero repercussions and now my ass is on
the line right but here he's she draws
in the lawyer but
watch what happens here it's beautiful
was that a note did he have a
conversation with you about being under
the rule
um
i don't believe so did he not tell you
you weren't supposed to discuss anything
that happened in this courtroom during
the trial
[Laughter]
so not only not only does this did this
guy lie straight to the judge's face
lied to her face right in that moment
because he finally realizes what what is
happening here yeah like in the end when
he says you know what i do remember the
rule i do remember the conversation
because she's drawing in the legal team
for contempt of court they're completely
[ __ ] they're they're egos they're
brash all this nonsense all this white
privilege [ __ ] all this stuff they don't
have
you know any consequences for their
actions is about to be wadded up and
thrown in the trash because right now
it's a catch-22 either the lawyers are
in contempt or he just committed perjury
right he's lying under oath and saying
it no they didn't tell me when in fact
they did because now the lord's like oh
no [ __ ] this guy we didn't tell him
that's
or like our ability to practice law is
not going to be [ __ ] up because this
dumb [ __ ] needs money to do a show and
continue spreading conspiracies
for alex jones like either
they
either they get their license at risk or
he gets uh charged with perjury it's
either way and i guarantee the lawyers
are like yeah we [ __ ] told him he's
under the bus right now well in this
judge uh jared points out she's pissed
and she's infuriated here but she holds
her composure and the reason why the
judge is holding her composure just
trying to get at what actually has
happened here
is because she can't make she can't make
this trial emotional for her now i don't
think the jury is sitting in the room at
this point but when you get heated in a
trial like this with a jury sitting
there like we saw with the written house
trial and how that judge really um you
know amped up the dramatics and [ __ ] for
for for the kyle rittenhouse trial you
know you really the judge starts to have
an effect on the jury which is not what
you want you just want the judge to
preside over the trial make sure it's
fair to all the people whether it's the
jury the defense the the you know the
the actual prosecution if you if you let
if you let that person that person on
the witness stand make a fool of the
court right and play their game like
written house
then you know especially if the judge is
like oh yeah you know take all the time
you need to cry and and whimper and
whatever you need as long as you have
enough time
to convert these jury members to feel
sorry for you right
and she's like yeah i'm not [ __ ]
doing that i'm gonna ask you direct
questions any why they're gonna lie to
me you're gonna tell me the truth so
you're lying to me great
attorneys can we confirm great one of
you two are [ __ ] right now and i don't
care which it is but somebody's going
under the bus now we gotta get the
bonehead of the week here because we're
past time but i got to show this this is
alex jones on infowars after the after
this happened yesterday
now we love watching him in his freakout
phases because it's
it's very very very entertaining the the
weird word salad that he uses but watch
as he freaks out here and i think he's
freaking out because of what happened in
the clip we just saw i am a human
supremacist i am a human supremacist
he's a human supremacist gabe i think he
made that clear what the [ __ ] does that
mean i don't know i can't figure it out
like he doesn't like dogs and cats i
don't know let's watch
that term will be the future war with
the robots and the ai what you're
hearing now is the entire future and
everything they tried to stop us from
doing
the the the uh he's at war with robots
now i don't get it he will not be alive
long enough to see a war with robots
okay
this [ __ ] guy man he he he has higher
blood pressure than i do people yeah
i i honestly i don't know how he does
that with his voice where every night he
doesn't go home i mean like who knows
maybe
behind closed doors when he's talking to
his wife or his children or family or
whatever he's like all right so uh let's
sell dinner now let's all go to the
table and get some make you know like
it's just it is honestly like yeah his
blood pressure like stroke level like i
am surprised that he is able to do this
as much as he does
without someone being like hey look
you're a medical concern you're all
overweight you're yelling
you
already have health
issues hot
there is something going on here like we
saw you you know take ivermectin
whatever if it was or actually or not on
on air like you do some dumb ass [ __ ]
with your body
uh and every day you're like this is
like yeah he's just gonna have an
aneurysm like he's gonna [ __ ] uh
short out and just like have a stroke
on on on stage no doubt one day this
will happen let's see if he has one here
on this clip our supremacy will not end
with this planet
we will people the stars we will
colonize we will green dead worlds
we will go interdimensional we will
unlock the secrets of the universe god
has laid them out like christmas
presents for his children what
and i am extremely honored to be in the
fulcrum and the heart of the fight to
bring our race
the human race
in a race for the future
i am honored to be here
and we will break the enemy we will
break the pedophiles we will break the
satanist because god already sent his
own
self down here to show us he could do it
god would never ask us to go through an
obstacle course he wouldn't go through
and now we're gonna go through what
christ did and we're gonna go through it
and we're gonna be destroyed but reborn
on the other side and now
back to the news
yeah
you know his use his use of religion to
justify his his message his the attempt
of like he's you know he's
just earlier in court
trying to defend his actions because
he's going to be taken down for
everything he's worth
right for the despicable things he said
about sandy hook
and terrible terrible things
and now
he's trying to say i am a savior i am
here to fight on your behalf and
everything i say is for the betterment
of you and the human race i mean that's
what he's saying and then he's trying to
use religion to justify that which we've
always seen years and years of history
of this type of [ __ ] where somebody uses
religion to say
this is why i'm doing this thing right
this is why i'm justifying this thing
god told me to kill this person god told
me
to make and spread conspiracies about
sandy hook
survivors and victims and families
and it was a god that told me
and somehow it all has to deal with the
human race like
he's out of his [ __ ] mind he's a
lunatic he's he's batshit crazy well
here's the thing i mean it's him trying
to play the victim is what it is what
exactly he's saying they're always the
victim they're always going to send me a
message that's right i'm defending you
it's all they're always the victim
here's here's the thing before we go to
the break and go to bonehead yeah
is the reason why it's relative relevant
is because
a large portion of these fascists that
are trying to take over our government
are not only trying to model alex jones
they're listening to him and they're
believing his garbage this [ __ ]
bonehead i wish he was on bonehead of
the week all right maybe he'll make
maybe he'll make the list next weekend
he's trying to get yeah as the trial
happens this is his trial
i think i think that is the thing and
then you know
let's play a commercial here we'll go to
a commercial break we'll come back with
bonen of the week but an appropriate
commercial for alex jones maybe he might
just seek a pardon uh pardon blanket
maybe we'll be right back with bonehead
right after these messages
we'll be right back mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your pardon blanket
today for just 99.99
actual partying is not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we're at the part of the show where we
do bonehead of the week it's gonna be a
short one this week but we bring it to
you every single friday
you vote
you decide
we break it down for you in the second
hour of the tony michaels podcast every
friday
bonehead of the week
let's get to it to the bonehead of the
week gabe
bonehead of the week i'm excited about
bonehead yeah also a quick a quick side
note i was attempting to call the alex
jones show because he's live right now
oh is he uh yeah i tried i tried to call
like 12 times 13 14 times didn't get in
there uh and it's just user busy user
busy user busy so some days someday i
will get through and we will have it on
the show live that's good that's we'll
try to we'll try to make that a maybe a
segment of how to get on the alex jones
show live
gabe this this uh bonehead does not
disappoint let's get right into it the
bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week we have some really big
boneheads of course
um two senators and a bought and paid
for supreme court justice uh samuel lito
senator susan collins and senator josh
holly
yeah
josh holly josh hawley hauling ass
colleagues
speaking of booking it now we'll get
into that yeah we'll get into that we'll
get into that so let's start with the
alito uh part because i actually have a
video clip of the alito yeah and where
he's
where he's doing a thing that supreme
court justices probably shouldn't do
um gabe can you give the audience a
sense while i'm looking for this year of
what he actually did here
yeah so uh foreign nations were
critiquing our you know our basic uh
response to what has been happening and
he mocked them right so he
he
which is so which is so odd right as a
supreme court justice you would not
outside of the opinion that you state in
your
uh your response to whatever the case
was you kind of shut the [ __ ] up after
that you really don't go out there
uh making more of it you just say this
is my job and this is what i do right
but he decided to go further
and and mock the foreign leaders who
were condemning the
the decision of roe v wade our friends
over midas touch put it uh eloquently as
always alito proving in front of the
world that the right-wing supreme court
justices are nothing more than a
political hacks unfit to serve on the
bench now here is the video where he's
mocking them let's let's listen to this
bonehead and then we'll move to the next
we got some boneheads to get to here
let's listen to this [ __ ] bonehead
over the last
few weeks since
i had the honor this term of
writing i think the only supreme court
decision in the history of that
institution
that has been lambasted by a whole
string of foreign leaders there there
might be a [ __ ] reason for that you i
know here i want to point something out
why is he trying to grow a shitty ted
ted cruz weird it was like you know
every everyone during kova thought hey i
could
grow a beer you know what but this is a
really shitty ted cruz type beard it's
not even a good one right i don't know
i'm just saying the guy the guy grows a
beer like he makes [ __ ] decisions on
the supreme court is all i'm saying
they're [ __ ] ridiculous okay let's
listen
who felt
perfectly fine commenting on
american law
one of these was oh for prime minister
boris johnson
but he paid the price
[Applause]
no
no one no one in the u.s can speak about
foreign policy and laws and no one in
there no one abroad can comment
other than him he can right he's a
fascist he's a fascist he can do that
right right right he's a white dude he
can do that right and he's and he's not
he's he's an american and he he he holds
the lifetime seat of a supreme court
justice so he's allowed to do whatever
the hell he wants can you do me a favor
and load in the video i don't well
yeah go ahead and load in the video uh
but let's let's listen
to what else this [ __ ] bonen has to
say and then we'll move to the next one
postdoc ergo propterhawk right
but others are still
are still
in office president macron and prime
minister
trudeau i believe are too
but what really wounded me what really
wounded me
was when the duke of sussex addressed
the
united nations and seemed to compare the
decision whose name may not be spoken
with the russian attack on ukraine
jesus christ this [ __ ] guy so so this
is the just for context this is the same
[ __ ] guy who quoted what it was a
17th century a jurist
who
prosecuted witches so the guy coming out
here trying to say uh let me go after
the people and mock the people that have
critiqued me taking away the rights of
women just a basic again health care
uh uh
right that we have right that women have
and he goes i didn't like the fact
because this is what he's really saying
he didn't like the fact that people made
fun of him he didn't like the fact that
he was the butt of the joke so he hired
some writers to write this little speech
that he gave and to make fun of those
people not very funny jokes because
those things are unrelated to the the
decision that was made it's like
whatever
but remember this guy
used a 17th century
jurist to say
for a witch trial for [ __ ] witches
to say oh yeah women
should should not have the right uh to
decide what they can do with their own
body like what the [ __ ] this is the guy
that wants to come after other people
talking about him
well even in the decision and this just
doesn't affect us i mean they're paving
the way for contraception to be banned
for for for same-sex marriage to be
banned which brings me to my next
bonehead
susan oh they've learned their lesson
collins that [ __ ]
pearls tony
all right
oh my god this this [ __ ] bonehead how
she's been on she's been on the list
several times she has been on several i
don't think she's actually won i might
have made her a dm one week about roe v
wade right well here she is
um
speaking of same-sex marriage um
you know that that schumer and mansion
have come to an agreement on the
inflation reduction bill
which does a lot for climate actually
which is surprising that manchin has
reached that agreement with schumer now
rather mansion holds true on that
agreement we'll see
but susan collins is basically saying
that if you're gonna get the same sex
marriage bill
you can't have the inflation reduction
bill so you gotta choose america you
gotta choose you either want the
inflation reduction bill or you want to
get gay married this is really [ __ ]
dead like what what kind of ultimatum is
this where you're going to put the
rights they're not even they're not even
two of the same things exactly but it's
also like you're gonna you're gonna put
the rights of those who have same-sex
marriages up for [ __ ] at stake and say
look you guys can either have this
marriage thing that you want or
we can deal with inflation like why
can't we have both why is it so why is
it so
like not even comprehensible to to say
like yeah as an american we would want
to fight inflation and bring that down
while also giving people the rights to
do whatever they want and whatever
relationship they want to get married to
whoever they want like
why why is it even a discussion of like
look you can only have one or the other
you got to pick which one is it going to
be tick tick tick tick tick like
they're [ __ ] ridic she's [ __ ]
ridiculous here
i mean absolutely she's saying you
either can have
the inflation reduction bill or you can
you can have your same-sex marriage bill
you can't have both she's like you gotta
choose and this goes back
to ted cruz fish bumping on the floor of
the [ __ ] senate because he's excited
that they killed a bill that he thinks
democrats want
yeah and it's not about democrats
wanting this bill it's about veterans
getting the [ __ ] health care they've
earned
jesus christ and democrats just want
that that's all they want is they just
want the ability for these veterans to
receive the health care they want just
like democrats don't want to tick back
and take away the right from people to
love who they want to love they don't
want to do that
you got this right why like these people
were given this right it took a long
time for these things to happen right
you had rights for women that you know
in the last uh 50 years have had you
have this one that was what 2008 i want
to say or chosen i forgot children no 13
2013 is when prop 8 was passed i believe
so now you're gonna like for the last
nine years
it's not only the people the couples in
the relationship that are affected it's
those in that family and anyone who was
adopted now you're like look
dad and dad mama mom whoever you are uh
were legally not viewed under the law
as your parents anymore
or as like
together
and now
you got to live in separate houses like
it's a whole [ __ ] thing where it's
like insanity what are we doing why are
we doing this right i mean like
obviously i know why republicans are
doing this
but the the the ultimatum is like you
can either have this or you can have
that like what does it mean you're
either gonna deal with inflation but
have your relationship
or we're going to bring down an ease
inflation but you lost that relationship
that you fought so hard to get and
you've had for less than a decade
it's craziness so there's why susan
collins made bonehead of the week along
with samuel alito
justice sami lido here he doesn't have
the ted cruz beard right this is before
i have not
this is the first time
because supreme court justice you rarely
see them out in public the only time is
when they're like at a gala or at a
function like this
but even then like it's very rarely
they're not they're not talking about
the way the only time you get a
photograph is when it's like the group
shot or individual shots that you'd find
on like the supreme court justice
website well i mean they like to go and
brett kavanaugh
likes to go to steak restaurants well he
he likes his beer and he likes his
ketchup on his steaks right right it
happens um someone else who probably
likes ketchup on steak is the
dishonorable mention of the week
representative marjorie hooffoot green
oh boy
oh my god what did she do why is she the
dishonorable mention you you put your
decision this what what why did you make
her dm this week she's you know not a
nazi
oh this goes back to the this because
he's a nazi
he's not a
nazi a national christian now see oh my
god what a [ __ ] bonud this one is i
we we talked about this yesterday you
know jessica denson came in and kind of
guessed co-host yesterday
yeah thank you to jessica yes shout out
to jessica denson again everyone go
follow jessica on twitter
at jessica denson07
make sure to go give her some love over
on twitter but we talked about the
christian nationalism yesterday and this
this [ __ ] boneheaded [ __ ] where
they're they're embracing
they're embracing their fascism
just straight up embracing it if i can
find the clip here oh here it is here it
is this is on um michael knowles
uh do you know who this dude he's some
kind of far right you know trader tv
news network podcast i don't know what
the hell this is
i don't know what the hell who the hell
this guy is looks like uh scott baio
yeah right right young scott baio
honestly right like a young chachi hey
chechi right
i mean you know this is more tucker
carlson alex ty stein type [ __ ] yeah
yeah no bow tie no ties yeah well casual
right cashmere sweater
casual rube a casual room not a not an
official rube right but listen to how he
introduces her first thank you so much
for coming on
thank you for so much for coming on
he's really excited that she's coming on
his show gabe
this is so nice to have a nazi on my
show
but you notice how they're really smiles
here the and i think the reason why you
put this er on the dishonored mention is
this clip is this the clip yeah yeah
okay
and i think it's i think it's very
telling in our country that republicans
who self-proclaim themselves as proud
christian nationalists
have to be asked the very first question
when they go on the show is like are you
a nazi because that's that's literally
what it learns here a lot of people are
saying that you're a nazi all right just
want to just want to get it out there in
the open let's
let's just let's just address the
elephant in the room you do a good
impersonation of him let's watch thanks
for having me on michael so first
question twitter is forcing me to ask
this
i guess i guess elon musk who owns
twitter now apparently
not um is forcing him to ask this
question you hear this you hear do you
hear
the the the i'm being forced oh my god
freedom of speech is at risk here gabe
because he's being forced at jesus
christ let's listen
are you now or have you ever been
a nazi a national socialist he can't
even say nazi
nationals not national or socialist are
you selfless you're right
natural is not so sourceless
like he can't did he even say nazi he
can't even say listen no i went through
this yesterday he did not he can't he
can't utter the [ __ ]
syllables out of his mouth because
god forbid
he he may cause excitement for because i
would bet that he thought oh my god
maybe if i actually ask her if she's not
she's like you goddamn right i am i mean
no no you don't know but watch or have
you ever been
a nazi a national socialist
the national
i don't know i don't know why he i don't
know why he fumbled on the nazis i don't
know if it was supposed to be one of
those where you're like oh you know yeah
like
josh hawley was running for i mean from
uh you know office or whatever like if
it was one of you like one of those like
er slip i mean kind of moments or if he
thought like in his head he's like don't
say nazi don't say nazi nazi nationals
yeah you know right he's trying to he
was trying to get the word socialist in
there it seems right right yeah to me
yeah yeah it sounded like it right you
know
because that's what they like to do you
know they're like oh
the democrats are the ones who started
the kkk like yeah sure okay that's
that's part of history right but if
you're going to ignore everything since
then okay that's yeah yeah you're right
then you're a [ __ ] bonehead the same
way as well they were called socialists
in nazi germany yeah but if you go look
at the history they weren't they weren't
what you're saying is a socialist that's
not what it was but okay
words friend but let's let's watch her
response to see if she claims she's a
nazi or not oh never i'm relieved to
hear that yeah that apparently they can
label you things you're not and lie
about you and smearing your character
on twitter and they think that's
perfectly okay
and this is what they have done to me
ever since i became a member of congress
all those people on twitter they they
type out on twitter gaming that she's a
nazi they need to stop you know what
needs to happen
someone a billionaire needs to buy
twitter and force people not to be able
to type out the things that they want to
type out and stifle speech that's what
should happen gabe that's what should
have we should that's what they want
that's right they won
they want free speech up until a certain
point right right
they want free speech you want to type
in nazi and then they're like oh well
you can't say did you really want to say
nazi and you're like yes he's like well
too bad you can't say nazi right you
know like oh no you can't call me a nazi
you can call someone else or not you
just ain't right nancy yeah exactly like
this margery taylor green be like no
never i was never that thing you know
it's like okay look she's like they've
been attacking me ever since even before
i was sitting in congress like that's
because you're a nazi you're also the
crazy woman who showed up when you were
not a representative you showed up to
aoc's office and started yelling into
her [ __ ] mailbox you're [ __ ] crazy
not only did she do that she filmed it
and then posted it on the internet and
then deleted it once i think might have
been patriot takes or somebody found it
and then deleted it and was like no i
never made the video just like when
patriot takes post of the text she's
like they're taking my words out of
context it's like
we're reading the background
it's an
they're taking my podcast out of context
you literally said these things you said
this july 4th shooting was oddly
suspicious of the conspiracy it's like
you said it you're the one saying on
your show no
nobody nobody edited they just cut the
thing that you said that's all well i
want to point out here because
she's on michael knowles show
and it almost looks like they have the
same background
i was like is she on the same set no no
no she's on her shoulder right yes she's
got her she has two she's got her show
marger taylor green and she's got the
mtg logo on the video
she has the she has the mike again in
the wrong she's knocking position right
exactly but she's also she's also not in
that weird ass hotel room no echoey
anymore because with a mic that's
pointed away from her right this this
mic
this mic is a dynamic mic which you have
to actually you have to talk directly
into it like this like if i was to but
mine is a condenser mic and that's the
kind of mic that she has at the hotel
thing whatever that is i don't know if
it's like a if it's like a back room of
a brothel or what the hell she's yeah
but also that mic she has has different
settings so it's like a cardioid or
whatever right yeah yeah i have
different words like i want to surround
right i want it just this part i want it
on this side you know if i'm doing like
a conversation between two people
because it's very similar to the mics we
have because right exactly you use a
yeti that's a yeti this is a yeti now
this one here is not a yeti this is a
dynamic mic it's like a radio mic you
have to talk directly into it which some
some people like those kind of
microphones i prefer a condenser
microphone so i don't have to eat the
microphone i can stay away and i'm
really loud so i like to be away from
the microphone so you guys don't have to
you know hear me too much but
but here she's again she's on this other
set which is weird that it seems like
she stole his background i'm just saying
it feels like she copycatted him here
i wouldn't be the first time that she's
copied
other people
and then try to take credit for it you
know or or or just try to rewrite the
story to be like i've always had this
thing you know right i've always
believed this thing you know i was
always a nazi i mean i was always a
national uh christian you know
a national christian a nat c let's
listen nancy a nazi
and i'm really tired of it i i am i'm i
it hurts me it hurts my family
it hurts my friends and it angers them
it also upsets people in my district
because they share the same faith that
faith that i have i'm a christian
and they also love our country just like
i do
so stop being a nazi
look you know you know what i would say
hurt her family and her relationship
with her husband and all these things
even worse
than this
accusation that people are making about
her the fact that she had two affairs
that we know of
with a a trainer at the gym that she
worked at
and also a tantric sorry a polyamorous
tantric sex guru so i don't want
marjorie taylor green coming here and
saying people are calling me these
things and that hurts my relationship
and my family and all these things i
know i know keep it together tony please
don't please don't throw up on the show
you can't put marjorie taylor green in
the same
sentence
look all i'm saying is you know she did
some burpees and then you know she was
full adam so
marcher taylor green cannot come out
here and make these things oh you know
it really makes me
me as a christian my christian faith if
you're really christian
you wouldn't have broken the goddamn ten
commandments
marjorie taylor green i'm a christian
and i love god and god told me to run
and man is the superior gender to me so
as a woman i actually shouldn't be
running because that's the logic she's
saying and another clip that we played
before she's also saying right now
that's like oh as a christian i was
tested and i it hurt my family and the
things that people are saying to this
one it's free speech two you've got to
prove that it's not true marge and three
if you really were a christian then you
would actually practice the teachings of
christ and follow him to say oh yeah i
love thy neighbor
i will not i will not murder i will not
plant a pipe bomb i will not have an
affair
thou shalt not plant pipe off
oh speaking speaking of people who have
[ __ ] blow up in their face
uh matt gatz is also on bonehead alpha
[ __ ] he got cucked big time dude holy
this was huge so tell the audience how
matt gets
stepped in and really got cucked here
all right so there is a a there is a uh
a gen z activist her name is olivia
she's from texas she's from texas she is
fighting the good fight um she's kicking
ass down there and she's only 19. she's
only 19. so i just want to set the
context for what's about to happen
matt gates goes to his [ __ ] student
action summit in front of teenagers
makes a speech about how women are are
fat and ugly makes us you know yeah we
we we actually covered the clip
that was over the weekend i think yeah
so that happened on monday right exactly
so
so that clip goes out there olivia was
like hey this is really [ __ ] up this
is fat phobic and this is uh
misogynistic like you're making this
speech this is terrible
he catches wind of that quote teats her
uh quote tweets her and then uh he said
i think dander file dander flight i
forget what the thing he quoted
so dander raised dander raised right so
then it becomes his back and forth right
where she's like oh
now he's calling me out and then a bunch
of people from his side that saw that
post started to come after her right so
she started getting threats and she
she she's got [ __ ] tough skin man she
took that she took that [ __ ]
alpha cuck dumbass
sex
trafficking
wannabe
man
and started to raise money off that to
say matt gates
as she said here well matt gates i have
to hand it to you i didn't think you
cared about us abortion right activists
but your spotlight and me has helped me
raise 50k for abortion rights in the
last 24 hours so i made a special thank
you card she makes a special thank you
card she did just the first 24 hours
that was just the first 24 hours
she was just getting started here dude
the [ __ ] engine was just revving up
she makes his thank you card she gives
people a temple she's like tell matt
gates thank you for what he's done
that's within the first 24 hours and
this [ __ ]
it was like a it was like kerosene on a
[ __ ] bonfire this thing blew up like
a bomb in a in a capital city type thing
exactly within 48 hours i think they
were over 300 000
within 72 hours tony
gen z
the the group that she's with
they have raised the gen z for change
group have raised over 1
million dollars wait wait with an m with
an
m with a capital m so here's her proof
for the first 24 hours this is at the
house because people were doubting her
people were saying she was lying
like this isn't this is a real just a
bunch of leftists and then she actually
got she actually got this hashtag
trending too
this is one half she got trending this
is the first one so she gets matt gates
is a pro abortion right so the updates
keep coming in you get 48 hours boom 24
hours let's hit 100k
within the next day
they've broken that and they had 115
thousand dollars that he raised because
of matt gates but now she's at a million
bucks but now she was on joy read she
was on all these other things she's like
talking about what's going on and here
she's lasting the message
right blasting the message
and getting it well over a million and i
think it's like
i want to say
close to 1.5 now well let's watch this
report from katie so you've called
gates's comments outright misogyny and
fat phobia we reached out to the
congressman's team about those body
shaming claims this is what we got back
from gates's spokesperson quote
congressman gates never mentioned the
adult's weight leftist media did what do
you think about that official response
from matt gates's office get him olivia
get him get him
i think it's quite telling that gates
office would try to keep the word
teenager out of the headlines
i'm matt gates and teenager trended
together it didn't end so well for him
okay okay gabe gabe i i think i think i
follow olivia i've been following her
for a while and i think she follows me
and i think your mutuals do we need to
get her on the show next week yeah i'll
reach out to her after i'll reach out to
her after the show and see if she wants
to come on i i i am in love with her now
just oh because i haven't she has
nailed her with the teenager thing oh my
god
dude it's it is [ __ ] making its
rounds and the joke here's the thing
just like josh hawley running away like
that'll never run out for sure
because you know whatever aj is a coward
and matt gates the same way his whole
sex trafficking you know allegations
let's call what it is it's a real thing
uh
that [ __ ] with teenagers
that [ __ ] will never run out he will
always have that over his head and
olivia here [ __ ] dunked on him again
and again and every [ __ ] time along
the way she does an interview [ __ ]
dunk she gets she raises 300k 500k 800k
a million 1.5 she keeps [ __ ] dunking
on them where right now she's hanging
off the rim and just [ __ ] keep magnum
and i'm gonna break the backboard baby
what's up the other the other interview
i saw with her she's not just gonna give
it to one organization she's gonna try
to distribute to all 50 states
exactly and trying to make sure this
money gets in the in the best hands of
of organizations in every state to make
sure that people who aren't receiving
abortion services are having trouble
receiving abortion services can receive
those services that save lives and and
help women get their actual health care
that they need so olivia if you can hear
me i love this
um what a beautiful beautiful cherry on
top
to make
matt gates
the alpha cuck cut the [ __ ] out of him
you did olivia oh my god
for bonehead of the week
she did a fantastic job fantastic job it
was amazing to have her on next week i'd
love to have her on next week um so i'm
gonna i'm gonna retweet this and uh give
her her credit for bonehead um and
here's the thing i don't see that
stopping i mean she could get the two oh
yeah 2.5 it's gonna
what could you cuz you know matt matt
gatz is gonna continue to be a pile of
[ __ ] right so yeah yeah if he's gonna
continue to be a pile of [ __ ] and she
can figure out a way to raise money off
that hell let's keep going right keep
going to raise money off this piece of
[ __ ] which brings me to uh i mean i even
said i said online i was like turns out
matt gates is actually the best
fundraiser for
abortion rights yeah you were sending me
you were sending me some stuff and i
i've been keeping an eye on this uh this
thing and of course monday we we railed
uh gates ourselves but the teenage the
teenager comment is uh
woo baby it was fantastic speaking
speaking of [ __ ] speaking of
[ __ ]
we have uh our bone end of the week our
winner uh senator
josh hall and ass i mean holly
josh holly look at him booking it just
[ __ ] got booked in it
so i i think that's the reason why
everyone has him on the well there was
also new news about what already it
turns out
yeah it turns out the masculine man that
is josh hawley right that [ __ ] pro
testosterone gonna [ __ ] do it as a
man
he's writing a book that's coming out
next may
yeah what's the title
it's called
manhood
uh hold on hold on i got i don't wanna i
don't wanna say it poorly here it's
called manhood if i had one maybe that's
what it is it's a
manhood
what is it
uh
yeah matt walsh what's a woman josh
hawley what's a manhood what is a
manhood no but josh hawley
uh i had a i have it here i have it here
um
manhood the masculine virtues americans
need not a joke this isn't like being
ironic this is not tongue-in-cheek this
is him the same man that i think it was
last year or so or a couple years ago
was saying that uh masculinity manhood
is under attack and he is victim number
one of course he is well he's a white
man here's what i said about the book i
said josh hawley writing a book called
manhood is like steve bannon writing a
book on hygiene what the actual [ __ ] who
would buy who would who would who would
buy a book from steve bannon
on hygiene
let's buy a book from josh hawley
on manhood are you [ __ ] kidding me
like the guy and this is all after the
fact of like he he the [ __ ] generous
here's it i just want to point out the
january 6 committee did not
did [ __ ] not have to do that
to josh hawley
right they didn't have to show that clip
yeah they could have just they could
have just they could have just talked
about it right they didn't have to they
didn't here they didn't even have to
bring it up they could have just jumped
over like we're gonna play the outtakes
of trump and we'll call it a day right
they [ __ ] went after josh hawley
because hard
hard that guy and they got him [ __ ]
good because what ended up happening is
they bring up the fact that oh yeah josh
hawley was out there he's like doing his
[ __ ] pro insurrection has fist bumped
all the pro trumpers and as soon as they
were like hey you guys got to get out of
the building because these [ __ ] got
in and they're coming they're [ __ ]
they see red and they're coming for
blood and like oh [ __ ] and he [ __ ]
guns it down the hallway they're like
what did what did what did trump call
pence what did he call him i forget what
was the a [ __ ] yeah a [ __ ] yeah yeah i
just i just want to bring that piece of
evidence just [ __ ] guns it guns it
down the hallway and they're like look
if you missed how fast this person ran
by let's put it in slow-mo
dude like just [ __ ] slow mo catch you
to be like this is josh hawley the same
guy that was pro-insurrectionist outside
[ __ ] riled him up and said if i was
out there with you i would keep in mind
he's [ __ ] protected
protected by the blue
that were there
fighting for their lives to make sure
that the people that didn't get in and
when they did get in joshua was [ __ ]
out of there he was gone he [ __ ] got
down the escalator he was out of there
okay who wants josh holly content here
let's let's see what this is
okay there's there's a little bit of
josh hawley content for you let's see uh
what else do we have cause i wanna i
wanna get to some video here um um
uh here's here's
where oh there's the there's the if you
want to play the forest gump video again
you can
yeah well let's let's do that yeah let's
let's play that one um i don't know this
may or may not be uh something a piece
of evidence that the january 6 select
committee didn't have or something hey
you you look like an elite i'm coming
for you
run holy run
you wouldn't believe it if i told you
but i could run like i was escaping an
insurrection
and from january 6th on
if i was going somewhere
i was running
[Music]
that boy is hauling ass you ain't
joshing
he's booking it he's booking it now
i want to point out i want to point out
we played that video when you released
it yeah yeah and it actually got banned
in russia of all places weird weird like
not here very weird not here we had a
strike on our not a strike but a notice
like a copyright notice we had a
copyright notice that somehow it was
banned in russia it was banned in russia
yeah
there's a connection between holly and
russia but you know i don't know uh let
me see if i can find
i'm trying to find the um
ah damn
where is it
i want the damn um the benny hill
version
uh
all right you played that give me a
second my computer's about to die i
don't know why hold on are you are you
gonna are you gonna lose out
i got two percent of my battery hold on
oh
man hold on i gotta pause it but you
keep you find the video you just won't
see me for a moment okay go ahead go
ahead we're gonna we're gonna i'm gonna
find the benny hill version here
we lost we lost sanchez here for just a
minute he's got a plug in his computer
um
down in the bunker not only is wi-fi
um very um
very scarce but also power apparently
um
here we go there we go
did you get it back yeah i got it back i
had to reconfigure some soros cables
over here
i'm trying to find this um
i think this is it this is it right here
okay here we go let's watch this one
more time and then we'll give josh holly
is due
[Music]
bye
oh it's fantastic it's because again
january 6 committee did not have to play
the video they couldn't they could have
you know made a comment about if they
really wanted to but they did not have
to show the video they did not have to
show the video in [ __ ] slo-mo but
they did because you know what
josh hawley can go [ __ ] himself so yeah
him he's writing a book called manhood
right the the uh the masculine virtues
americans need which is
hilariously ironic uh not intentional
but as i joked about like eddie you know
with each book you'll get a free pair of
running shoes you know
um
that's
bonehead of the week you voted and it
was overwhelming yeah there was no
question josh holly was the bonehead so
let's give him on each one youtube and
twitter he blasts it through let's give
him his dude
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and there you have it josh own end of
the week everybody i don't know what was
faster him on that in that race or him
running down the hallway in the january
6 video who knows it was a hell of a
race it was a hell race and if you want
to vote on bone of the week go to at
toni michael's pod follow us there you
can vote every single week for bone out
of the week where you decide who the
bone of the week is and we break it down
for you every single friday make sure to
subscribe to the youtube channel as well
because you do not want to miss an
episode of bonehead of the week
stick around we will have some news
right after
the music
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
bone end of the week my favorite of the
week my favorite segment it's it's great
i love it my favorite yeah well we got
some news for bonehead of the week
because next week is going to be a
little different
um we have our executive producer and
co-host you guys know him as dirty gabe
sanchez dirty sanchez um
hey listen you are gone a couple days i
know i get to say whatever i know it's
fine i haven't i haven't played the
tapes yet just like that judge but if i
do i know did you call me that
you should go back and look at the tapes
but here here's here's what i'll say
next week is going to be a little
different we're going to put the
bonehead of the week out on wednesday
and then
[Music]
we may or may not record it
sometime thursday and play it friday but
we will play both end of the week
friday in the second hour we will have
bonehead of the week delivered to you so
be looking for
the poll for bonehead of the week on
wednesday as opposed to thursday next
week just go to tony michael's you can
vote there or you can vote here on
youtube subscribe to the youtube channel
don't forget to also download bonehead
of the week every single sunday we will
post the bone of the week that we just
did on sunday on apple spotify google
all your favorite directories give us a
five star review over there on those
directories
as you go download those
gabe i'm glad this week is over next
week is bound to be crazy
back next week is bound to be crazy but
i'm happy that we're here to the end of
the week because every single week we go
monday through friday two hours every
single weekday on youtube twitter twitch
and we simulcast from the minus touch
facebook page
everyone have a safe and great
weekend
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking